Oh
At some point in our lives most of us have probably wished we could live forever
Being immortal sounds pretty good at first essentially not aging after a certain point being unable to die of natural causes not a bad life
But what if everyone became immortal overnight? What if the entire worlds population
stopped dying at the current rate approximately 150 to thousand people die every day around the world
That's about two per second
So assuming our immortality event happens instantly that would mean two unlucky souls would miss it by as little as a fraction of a second
If we assume everyone stopped dying at the time of making this video the world
population would quickly start climbing from about seven point six billion
At the current rate about three hundred sixty thousand people are born each day and the current death rate slows apparent population growth by about
42%
When this immortality event occurred we'd begin to see dramatic changes to our society
Contrary to what you'd probably expect
Overpopulation wouldn't be the first problem. We'd have to deal with if people stopped dying the population would start to increase more quickly
But it wouldn't become a crisis for at least a few years
one of the first negative impacts of this change would likely be the ironic death of the funeral industry if
No one dies of natural causes. There's no one to bury no funerals to arrange
No caskets to sell
Funeral homes would have to rely on victims of violent crime car accidents and other unnatural causes of death to make a living
Meanwhile in hospitals people sick with formerly terminal illnesses would exist in a permanent state of pain unable to die and their families would be
Stuck with their continued medical bills these hospitals would begin to become overcrowded as new patients are admitted for various unnatural injuries and conditions
when the world begins to feel the strain of overpopulation
Especially after children are born grow up and start having children of their own. We'd begin to see crises in several areas
First natural resources would be depleted at an alarming rate
Fossil fuels already running out today would be used up much more quickly forcing the world to adopt new sources of energy to keep society
running
Available land supply would dwindle with new housing springing up in any vacant lot to accommodate the rapidly growing population
Even if we could keep up with the demand for housing young people entering the job market would be met with little to no
Opportunity for employment all the jobs already snatched up by those who came before them as the unemployed begin to pile up
Homelessness would become a real problem made worse by the spike in housing prices when space inevitably runs out
Natural food would come at a premium as land used for livestock or crops
Would dwindle and suffer under the strain of so many new mouths to feed
The food industry would have to turn to heavily processed and cheaply manufactured food potentially causing even more widespread nutritional problems than we have today
With so many people out of work homeless and hungry and with no room to spread out civil unrest would start building
We'd begin to see riots in the streets of major cities anywhere
There's a concentrated population of the unemployed on a larger scale nations without room for their citizens may feel the obligation
To challenge their neighbors for their territory or resources sparking large Wars
governments would probably secretly see these Wars as serving multiple purposes to expand their territory and living space but also to help thin the
Population then there are more extreme possibilities with all other options exhausted perhaps we'd see a real-life
implementation of death sports like those in The Hunger Games or ancient Rome
May be forced
Euthanasia would become the norm for the unfit both young and old in order to allow the healthiest members of society to survive
Or more realistically we might see stringent restrictions on the number of children allowed per family perhaps based on social status
Occupation or income but if we could get the population growth under control the human race might not be as doomed as we think
We'd certainly have to live more frugal lives and likely have much less space to spread out
But with the right regulations in place it could be
Sustainable at least for the near future in the wake of our new immortality we might see new
Technologies developed to accommodate the larger and longer lived population homes designed to allow humans to live in areas once considered undesirable
Allowing the more adventurous people to have a bit more space at the expense of safety or convenience
Technological progress would likely increase as the demand for new innovations to help ease the population strain would grow and longer lives would allow
Scientists and innovators more time to perform studies and develop new ideas
Provided the world didn't collapse beforehand on a personal level we might become more creative and artistic
our longer lives allowing us to pursue new hobbies and skills over decades instead of limiting ourselves to
A few we'd have the chance to live smaller mini lives living in one place for 50 years
Then moving and pursuing a new career somewhere else if the world could sustain such a drastic change
It would be interesting to see what an immortal society would look like of course
It's very unlikely that it would as the strain from so many new mouths to feed and people to house would simply be too much
Luckily immortality probably isn't something will ever have to accommodate and certainly not overnight
What do you think what would an immortal society look like and what changes would you expect to see in the world?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments below if you enjoyed this video
Make sure to subscribe to keep up to date with the latest content
You can watch my previous video by clicking here, or if you're really bored you can binge watch all my content by clicking here
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you next week